[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  oh my god I'm so sorry it's just I'm not  used to seeing you without your makeup  on you think I need a little um you know  what you probably need a little more  something just like to even you out I  mean it's HD yeah it's very good you  would dry what's allergies now did you  have kale for a hundred kale yeah okay  well listen I'm all ready to go I'll see  you out there you get some makeup on all  right pal oh and hey listen they brought  me some lunch but I'd already eaten so  help yourself you can have it great  thanks I'll see you out there  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  now  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]